let's talk about young men specifically
from your gentleman's perspective where
are men
really struggling what do you think is
the biggest problem out there
purposefully for young men in america
today purpose
not having the lack of men
have been systematically socially
engineered to be denied purpose men
we're innate problem solvers and when i
i always refer back to and it wasn't
actually jordan peterson who coined this
phrase i just found that out but like
the lost boys generation or the uh the
uh the dropout generation is what it was
before that even and it's the guys it's
it's a generation of guys who are laying
anywhere between like say 18 and 29
something somewhere around there and
they are absolutely rudderless in life
that's why these shows are so popular
that's why andrew was so popular that's
why i'm popular that's why you're
popular because these guys are looking
for the dad they never had that's why
jordan peterson was such a sensation at
least for you know about 18 months there
from 2018 to wherever he is now um the
the point being is that there are there
there are sheep looking for a shepherd
right now because they either were
denied a a positive masculine role in
their life or else they've been con i
asked this question all the time where
do men go to become educated today
because we constantly tell them don't go
to college you can waste your time you
don't want to take out those loans you
don't want to be at a disadvantage you
don't need college you don't need
education you don't need to go to
university you'll end up a communist or
you'll end up with blue hair and under
you know your lady and underarm hair you
look like lena dunham coming out of
college right so we discourage that
education and probably rightly so
because again it's another institution
that used to be something that was had
some value to it i have two degrees i've
felt like i've got some education out
that out of that i was able to write
these books as a result of being
well educated on a lot of variety of
things and if i didn't know something i
can go and find out right but what we're
telling guys right now is don't do this
don't do this don't do this don't go to
school don't do that and then people
like okay well what do i do and so
that's how that's why you get a jordan
peterson who's so seductive to say hey
well come to my shows and here's what
i'm going to tell you some you know very
profound you know things but they leave
the auditorium and they still are
purposeless and they still don't know
what they're going to do that's why you
have incels that's why you have you know
that's why we have the uh the lost boys
generation right now is because men are
natural problem solvers but we have no
problems to solve all the frontiers have
been explored right now and that's the
number one question i get and i'm sure
everybody else they're making you can
monetize
they don't know what to do i i know you
don't want to give the prescription
you've been you've been very vocal about
that but i'm gonna i'm gonna
ask you
what where should men find purpose these
days well i'll tell you where they are
finding it they're finding it online
right now and
that's what that's where they're finding
it but what should they do about it
again it depends on the individual i
would have to know what their particular
talents are where are they in the world
that's another reason why i don't
presume to give prescriptions i am a 54
year old white male living in the united
states right now i would not presume to
tell the 18 year old kid in you know
mumbai
here's how here's the secret to success
kid in mumbai i'm not gonna
i respect that i have i have the tools
for you to go figure it out on your own
to build a life but i'm not going to
tell you how to go and construct that in
fact i want to see your work i want to
see what you build with these tools i
think and that's where we go back to
that initial question who do you want to
be whether you're the 54 year old white
guy in america or the 18 year old kid in
mumbai who do you want to be if you can
answer that question you can somehow
find your purpose can i ask you the
exact same question what do you see as
the biggest problem with young men in
america today or even in the world yeah
i think identity i think there's a
demonization to be masculine absolutely
i think i think there's an isolation
happening because of the internet and in
a weird way it connects people but it
isolates them even more it's a it's an
extra version that everybody it's an
introversion that everyone thinks is an
expert yeah and i think that you can see
everything in the world but you can just
be in your home in your basement you
have so many so many access to so many
people and so many different opinions
and so much different information and so
it's could be tough to know you're up
from you're down and i think if i'm if
i'm a man
today and i i was around you know my
high school the internet was starting to
take off and then it was like my space
early college years and so these things
were starting to populate but i think
there's different challenges and so i
think you're so inundated with so much
information that you don't really know
what to do sensory overload yeah sensory
overly you don't really know what to do
and then when you don't know what to do
you just end up doing nothing you just
end up playing video games right that's
what they say if you're gonna if you're
sales people out there you can have
option a or option b or option c of this
you can choose this it's like give
people two options or three options
they'll make a decision by the way
that's pretty ten options that's what i
my my let's have a complaint but my main
complaint when we start talking about
what is a high value man right like guys
want to get from point a to point b
right well when i when you see an andrew
tate and he's living the lifestyle he is
or and not just him that could be just
like lower limit bush league guys who
are kind of like him guys like young men
look up to that and they see what he's
living the lifestyle he's living but for
most of those guys they can't relate
with being draped over a lamborghini
they can't relate with being on a super
yacht in the sea of oman let them dream
bro
well that's why i keep trying that
that's been my my my purpose or my point
is to when when i'm talking about the
rate it has to be for the every man it
has to be for the same guy who is in
miami as the same guy who's on a tractor
in oklahoma in the midwest somewhere it
has to be relatable to all men that's
why i get really pissed off when we talk
about the black manosphere the latin
atmosphere the asian atmosphere the
white mansford this no we're all men and
we all have the same we all have we're
all in the same boat right here and if
we're not we will be soon so that's why
i keep saying we need to make it
relatable for everyone finish your
thought but he said purpose you said
identity and purpose identity so if i go
back to where i was at high school my
father wasn't in my life my mother was
divorced uh she abandoned more or less
my father was the one that was
hypergamous
in terms of marrying someone that was
younger than him or you know more
attractive than my mom and we're all
good now but i didn't have a ton of
direction i didn't have a ton of
guidance i didn't have a ton of purpose
and so if i'm reverse engineering i'm
i'm giving people the prescription for
what worked for me as someone that is in
the west of able-bodied and sound mind i
don't have any physical ailments i don't
have any mental disabilities um and i've
been able to come from the bottom
objective poverty to doing fairly well
for myself and so the prescriptions i
think rollo saying he wants to go as
wide as possible i'm saying hey if
you're in in these sorts of situations
here are the things i would be focusing
on late you know late teens to early 20s
i wouldn't be spinning plates i wouldn't
be doing all this all trying to chase
tail and all these different things at
the club i wouldn't be doing any of this
stuff i would be working on hey what
scare skills do you have how is your
network who do you know do they know you
do you add value to them who who uh what
are your soft skills you know and do you
want to build a life with somebody
because you're way more likely to be
stable emotionally in a marriage when
done right and i think there's a lot of
being done wrong but i think when done
right it could be the the biggest
catapult and so for me my wife i was 23
she was 21. you were a little older when
you got married when you were 23 28 yeah
so i was 23 she was 21. um
uh i didn't i had three sexual partners
she had none okay so uh woohoo for me
married a virgin
and we were able to start bottom of the
barrel and build an amazing lives for
ourselves you know because of some of
these
basic concepts like delaying
gratification like living on less than
what you make like not spending any time
playing video games i have to do a hard
cutoff with video of games right like
because it was comments like xbox was
starting to take off everybody's playing
online no video games for me of course
yeah sedation and so there were specific
things that i needed to do
that tipped the scales in my favor and
continued to tip the scales in my favor
and i'm saying it's going to work for
everybody that's fair but it can work
for most men who are of able body sound
mind in the west make these sorts of
decisions sauce you can talk about money
all day
thank you for the team it up right there
i say this all the time whether it's
video games whether it's netflix whether
it's fantasy football you have two
choices with your time your most
precious commodity other than your
health health is number one is that you
can either invest your time or you can
spend your time yep take your pick
these days all i do is invest my time
i'm not saying that sometimes i won't
spend a little time doing whatever but
for the most part i'm looking at time as
a
commodity and it's the most precious
commodity exactly other than health and
the older you get the more precious it's
like you talked about the other day
listen i'm in my mid 50s now i'm trying
to time is what i'm working on right now
but if you can invest your time wisely
there's only so success at the other
side of that rainbow so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
[Music]